What would television be without Netflix?
Wait, stop — it's too unbearable to even
imagine.
Netflix's introduction of show after awesome
show in 2016 left TV watchers hardly able
to catch their breaths, and it doesn't look
like Netflix is going to slow down in 2017.
With a miles-long list of series to binge-watch
in the coming months, here are the Netflix
shows that will blow everyone away in 2017.
Frontier
Frontier premiered on Discovery Channel Canada
in November 2016 to some seriously solid ratings,
and made the move to Netflix mid-January 2017,
giving TV lovers the perfect excuse to watch
all six episodes in a single sitting.
This Canadian-American period drama chronicles
a band of men battling to reclaim ownership
and seize control of the fur trade in 18th-century
North America, and there's one familiar face
that may very well have fans cheering.
Game of Thrones' Jason Momoa, better known
as the beloved Khal Drogo, is back on the
not-so-big screen!
Frontier is a multi-perspective series that
weaves through cultural relations and the
savagery of America in its adolescence.
Not only does the show promise a healthy portion
of violence, insane action sequences, and
sharp dialogue, but it also presents a historical
glimpse into the preindustrial times in North
America.
Education and entertainment?
That's a win-win.
Santa Clarita Diet
Sheila and Joel Hammond may seem like a normal
suburban pair of real estate agents, but their
fridge tells another story.
If you love zombie stories, but you're looking
for relief from the constant misery of The
Walking Dead, be sure to check out the comedy-horror
series Santa Clarita Diet, which premiered
on Netflix in early February.
Starring Drew Barrymore and Timothy Olyphant
as a California couple, Santa Clarita Diet
follows Sheila's radical transformation, who
may end up biting off more than she can chew
— literally.
Mindhunter
Based on the book of the same name, this Netflix
series rolls time back to 1979 with Jonathan
Groff and Holt McCallany starring as FBI Behavioral
Science Unit special agents who take on the
daunting task of conducting interviews with
currently imprisoned criminals.
But not just any criminals: these two sit
eye-to-eye with serial killers.
With Charlize Theron and David Fincher in
Mind Hunter's executive producer seats, brace
yourself for a drama that will leave you sleeping
with the lights on.
Marvel's Iron Fist
Superhero films, series, and spinoffs are
huge hits with audiences worldwide.
Recently, Netflix rolled out a triple threat
of comic crime-fighting shows in Marvel's
Jessica Jones, Luke Cage, and Daredevil.
In 2017, Netflix is adding yet another superhero
show to its stable: Marvel's Iron Fist.
The fourth Marvel series to find its home
on Netflix, Iron Fist stars Finn Jones in
the title role.
Billionaire Buddhist monk Danny Rand has returned
to his home city of New York after spending
years as a recluse, honing his unparalleled
martial arts prowess.
Danny summons the power of — you guessed
it — the Iron Fist, as he takes down New
York's most corrupt villains with a deadly
punch.
The series hits Netflix in full on March 17,
2017, and helps set the stage for...
Marvel's The Defenders
Though an official release date has yet to
be announced, Marvel's The Defenders will
definitely be buzzed about right up until
it reaches screens, and likely well beyond.
The eight-episode miniseries brings together
all of those heroes audiences know and love
from their standalone shows: Krysten Ritter
as Jessica Jones; Mike Colter as Luke Cage;
Charlie Cox as Daredevil; and the guy we just
talked about, Finn Jones as Iron Fist.
Also joining the superhero-studded character
ensemble are Elektra Natchios, vigilante nurse
Claire Temple, and the sophisticated and sinister
villain, Alexandra.
The group takes on all the bad guys in mid-2017.
Bill Nye Saves the World
If you were American and in school during
the '90s and early '00s, you likely remember
the notoriously catchy theme song to the live-action
educational science show, Bill Nye the Science
Guy.
"Bill Nye The Science Guy!"
The famed science educator and mechanical
engineer who taught viewers about cells, photosynthesis,
and the mysteries of the night sky is back
— this time for his very own talk show.
Bill Nye Saves the World will go beyond the
realm of just science, extending into politics,
fiscal and social trends, and pop culture
phenomena across the globe.
With a lot of interesting ground to cover,
Nye calls in backup with a few special field
correspondents, so audiences can learn about
the wonders of the world and its people, places,
and things as Mr. Nye debunks myths and refutes
anti-science claims in spring 2017.
Wet Hot American Summer: Ten Years Later
Despite being a box-office bust, 2001's Wet
Hot American Summer was a cult-favorite comedy,
with a talented cast that included Molly Shannon,
Paul Rudd, Elizabeth Banks, Michael Ian Black,
Bradley Cooper, and Amy Poehler, just to name
a few.
Nearly a decade and a half later, fans still
wanted more, so Netflix released an eight-episode
prequel series in the summer of 2015, which
was ridiculous in the best way possible: all
the actors reprised their roles, only to play
even younger versions of their beloved characters.
Next comes Wet Hot American Summer: Ten Years
Later, in which the cast collaborates once
again, this time at a more age-appropriate
level.
The sequel series is set in 1991 and is inspired
by some classic '80s comedies.
Friends from College
Starring one of the funniest funny men out
there, Keegan-Michael Key, alongside How I
Met Your Mother's Cobie Smulders, Friends
from College's premise is one that becomes
reality for almost everyone: you and your
once-rowdy college friends are officially
middle-aged — and you're coping with it
in some pretty interesting ways.
"Sorry, sorry.
We're going streaking!"
Dark
We all know how captivated audiences were
in the summer of 2015 when Making a Murderer
made its Netflix debut, subsequently taking
the TV-watching world by storm with its winding
tale of drama, behind-the-scenes footage,
and shocking secrets.
It seems history will repeat itself with Dark,
a family drama that tracks the trauma and
devastation that rock a small German town
following the mysterious disappearance of
two children.
While it's a work of fiction, it seems the
show is guaranteed to incite goosebumps and
grim realizations in its audience throughout
its 10-episode first season.
Big Mouth
It's not all going to be gritty thrillers
and action-filled shows coming to Netflix
in 2017.
This tongue-in-cheek, slightly risky animated
comedy from Nick Kroll and Andrew Goldberg
has been a long time coming: as Kroll put
it in a Netflix press release, "Andrew and
I have been best friends since first grade,
so this show is over 30 years in the making."
Not only does Kroll serve as creator, he's
also voicing one of the main characters: himself.
Girlboss
Sophia Amoruso's acclaimed autobiography Girlboss
is getting the Netflix adaptation treatment
in a series centered around the clothing brand
entrepreneur's rise to success.
Starting off humbly selling vintage threads
on eBay, Amoruso shot into international stardom
after starting up the wildly popular and wickedly
trendy fashion-brand-turned-empire Nasty Gal,
and this comedy series will explore her story
with its 13 episode debut in April.
Ozark
Filmgoers saw Jason Bateman play a slightly
more sinister character than his usual goofball
charmer in Joel Edgerton's 2015 thriller The
Gift.
Now, Bateman's settling into another sordid
role in Netflix's upcoming series Ozark.
Bateman stars as a financial planner who packs
up his life in the Chicago suburbs and heads
to a home near the Lake of the Ozarks in Missouri.
But his intentions aren't so squeaky clean...
Stranger Things 2
Following up on their breakout first season,
the Duffer Brothers will return to Hawkins,
Indiana for some more monstrous throwback
fun with Stranger Things 2, which debuts on
Halloween.
The second season of Stranger Things will
pick up a year after the first season left
off, after its crew of kid adventurers defeated
the Demogorgon — but lost contact with their
friend Eleven in the process.
If the Super Bowl previews for Stranger Things
2 are any indication, the intensity of the
show's second season is going to be full-tilt,
and fans will be tempted to ditch out on the
usual trick-or-treat routine for an evening
spent watching every episode of the new season.
Count on Stranger Things 2 to be even, well,
stranger than the first season, with a storm
coming along to bring some new otherworldly
baddies into the small town fold.
Dear White People
2014 saw the indie film Dear White People
bring racial tensions in a bright-white community
to the surface, and handled it with a ton
of smarts and satire.
Piggybacking on the original film comes the
television adaptation of the same name, with
a group of Ivy League students of color navigating
their nearly all-white Winchester University
campus to discover not only is the lack of
diversity shocking, but so is the number of
misinformed or just plain biased students.
El Chapo
Netflix seems to have kept its eye on the
foreign entertainment realm heading into 2017,
as the company has teamed up with Spanish
language broadcast network Univision for this
upcoming drama series centered around real-life
drug lord and wanted criminal Joaquín Archivaldo
Guzmán Loera, more commonly known by his
nickname, "El Chapo."
The drama series, based on the trials and
insane illegal endeavors of Guzmán's life,
will hit UniMas audiences before it reaches
Netflix subscribers, but when it does, it
promises to deliver big time.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!